[音楽]
ni
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは今村と申します今日朝7時の電車に乗ってこの松本ができたんです
けど僕はまあネーションパレットという間
東京の会社で8こういった cg を使った仕事をしています
影響ですねちょっと女さんに
映像の未来の話をしにここに来ました
デボカーペットどういったことをやっているかと言うと簡単にちょっとご紹介しようか
なと思います
やって今我々は cg でえっと
テレビアニメーションを作っていますこれですね
チーズスイートホームという作品なんですけれど
越冬その中でこの傷通って作品を撮りながら泥がいらっしゃいません
結構いらっしゃいまさね3分の1以下1/4ぐらいいらっしゃるとかね
えっと実はこれえっと講談社のモーニングっていう雑誌でだいぶ前に連載していた作品
なんですけれど
とこの
作家のを波からた先生っていうのはして実はここの松本出身ということを聞いており
ます
えっと今我々はこの作品を頭アニメーションを作ってるんですけど
このなが松本から生まれた作品が日本で放映されて実はちょっと後で紹介しますけれど
世界でも放映される作品になっています
というのがあやって今我々の仕事です
で衛藤この
実は音作品ですね全部
度コンピューターグラフィック cg で作られています
この
アニメーションで実はそのセルアニメーションっていうのが今の日本の手榴弾です
けれど一番1枚
手書きで何口もなんかも書いて売っているが埋まって何名称だったんですか
今この cg アニメーションっていうのが少しずつ普及しています
日本でもいくつかあるんですけどこの子猫後
ポッポーらー大冒険っていうのも実はフル cg で作られています
cg ってなんかちょっと難しそうだなあって思える方結構いらっしゃるじゃないかな
と思います
でも実はちょっとそうじゃないんだよっていうのを少しちょっとご紹介したいなと思っ
ています
僕は政治海野ずーっとまあ高校生ぐらいとか今始めたんですけれどもそこからズームし
塩が出てきて
よく聞かれることをいくつかあるんですね
まずその一つ目
cg ってもう凄い難しいコンピューターのプログラミングできないとできないんです
か
よく聞かれます
実は先を聞かれました
でも全然そんなことないですよ越冬
実は cg アニメーションを作っている家のオフ楽
中はにや元の人間は
とプログラミングなんか全く出来ませんしコンピューターにもう全く歌い人もたくさん
いたりします
そういったその当プログ loving が必要のポイントは絶対に今あるんですけど
実はそれだけじゃなくていろんな
この cg
えっとたくさんの中に仕事を持っています例えば a 4株仕事後はその
cg って仮想空間に等実際にモデルというそのものを作っていくんですけれどその
pc の中に実際にえっと3次元の空間をつくります
そこに例えば猫の造形をする人あとは文一の贈呈をする人とその人の造形に動く仕組み
れる人
あとはそれを動かす人たくさんのえっとまぁ人が関わってこういった指示の作品ができ
ています
って2つ目ちょっとよくこれも聞かれるんですけどね
と cg まあ結構こういったアーティスティックな作品多いので絵を描けないとでき
ないんですかという質問も結構あります
えっと実は僕は全く手をかけません
だけ僕は cg 始めたかというとですね
a ドーマー高校生のときにまあ多分にもれず
てたくさんしたりとかアニメをたくさん観てたんですけど
こういったものの作り自体があっその時に思ったんですね
ただ
美術のがこう言ってるわけでもないし絵を描けるわけでもないし
じゃあどうしようかなぁと思う時にこの c というえーっと
ツールに出会って
なんか描けなくても何か物創りできるじゃん
なんかこの仮想空間の中に頭ものを言ったら勝手に石が計算してくれて何か新しいなぁ
と思ってそこからずーっと
20年間この知事にはまってやっていきました
もちろんその道簡単なことばかりではないですけれど
ただ越冬昔 cg っていうのですねえっ結構もう20年前30で前というは
[音楽]
ブーブー言っにょだったんですけど今はもう
いう環境なので
自宅でえっとこういった作品作りをしている人たちも今たくさんいます
というぐらい越冬 ocg の垣根っていうのはだいぶ低くなってきています
で a
どうこういった cg ですねえと僕はマート裏からて作り続けているんですけれど
桃まあこういったアニメーション作品だと僕らをやっているのがですねえっとテレビの
cm だったりとかあとはゲームの映像
家ことは映画ですね映画の vfx そういったことも支持前へ行っています
史実ですねえっとぉある意味校
なんていうのかな
ゼロから会をつくる力を持っていてええなにもないところにとても
リアルスティック段目を作ることもできます
た一方その
制限を全くないのでただば映画であったらその底にある絵をカメラで撮るという作品を
作り方なんですけど
cg は本当に何もないくらい分間の中から
自分らの想像力ですべて作っていくのでそれにこういったその
いろいろ触れみたいな自分たちの走力をカタチにするツールになっています
えっとじゃあを支持何がいいかマートンとことができるかとまぁちょっとご紹介しよう
かなと思います
まあアニメーションこういった形で作れますあと映画の vx とさっきみたいに作れ
ます
あと最近ですね流行りの vr んですね
バーチャルリアリティここにもう必ず
cg 3次元の支持のが登場します
vr のは何もないところに越冬実際の下方の空間を作るわけなので
この3次元の cg っていうのが非常にいろんなところで使われています
なので越冬こういった指示だも新しい分野にもどんどんとつ変わっていく作業ですね
あとは vr に近いですけれど air
あー日面取り it こういったその現実世界と仮想空間を眺め選ぶために
ビジュアなビジュアルを上げるためにもこういった史実のたくさん使われています
あとまあ皆さんちょっと身近なところではですね例えばえーっと
去年おととしぐらいまで結構やっていたなプロジェクションマッピング
亜子皆さんもあの
得られないかと思うんですけど抜毛とちょうどやってたんですかね
えっとこのプロジェクションバッティング最近この
もてはやされたのはなぜかというとですねこの cg の技術が結構入ってきたからな
んですね
えっとプロジェクションマッピングなんかとてもあの
難しいことをやっているように見えますけど
実はあれはその
実際に立てばを後ろにプロジェクションマッピングをする場合ですね
シェイキーでます
お城を加速感情に作ってしまうんですよね
で
それに反して
映像を投影するから
実際の形にゆがんだ形の映像
事前にコンピューターで計算してから高齢数
だからは行った不思議なことができたりします
[音楽]
というのがまあ cg
色んな可能性を秘めていますその
抜くらは某エンターテイメントだけやってますけれど今後はその例えば
フィルマーボ cg の酒井出てきますし医療用いろんな cg が出てくると思い
ます
こういった形で
道
まあ
具体的じゃあ指示何か言うとですね本当にさん入った形のように
僕たちの創造力を
形にするチュールですが例えば a 事が日本語とかそういった言語のようなあくまで
も手段でしかないんですけど
この手段っていうのが非常に皆
楽になっていてさっきもお話しした通り
何もないところから作れたりするのでしかもしかも自分のパソコンで作ったようなもの
が世界でていける
ものになっていくという僕は魔法の距離だと思っています
最後ですねちょっとこの子猫のチーム本ポーラー
大冒険っていうのものは今回 cg 作ってわけですからね cg で作っているのか
ちょっとご紹介したいと思います
ブーバー amazon プライム
遊会とネット配信
もう世界廃止同時配信で行っています
なのでえっ日欧朝羊の見た瞬間に遠い国の人たちが同じ作品を見ている
こうやって結構すごいことだと思いませんがん
越冬
日本のアニメーションをセグアニメーションでま
実は海外に行くともちろん人気のあるものは人気があるんですけどどうしてもその
子ども向けというところで人気な作品史上なんですね
here それで4試合
名所です
まあなぜこういうことになっていることですね
今世界のグローバルスタンダードのアニメーションはセールではなく
cg になっています
なので僕らもあえて今このセルのアニメーションではなくて cg というツールを
使って
こういった松本で生まれた作品を
映像化することによって
セカエ
日本じゃなくて世界に打っていくというのを僕らは今チャレンジしています
[音楽]
という話でまぁ
ここに今いらっしゃる方がど実際に今こういった作品作りをマーサいう形かどうか
ちょっと分からないですけれど
今日ちょっともこういった cg てーちょっとでも面白い店を持っていただけたら
今日の僕の話は成功かなと思います
今日はありがとうございました